o gol
eu amo jogar é outra obrigado por
obrigar a organização prometeu convidar
para vir aqui e espero com impaciência
para 9 falar 10 minutos sobre uma coisa
que olhando pra vocês provavelmente se
quedaram 17 óbvio e o que eu tenho para
falar hoje e se conseguir conquistar
este meu texto das pessoas não mandam no
mato e olhando pra vocês
além desses que nem houve pressa gente
que das pessoas no marcas normais as
pessoas normais estas não têm nada
transcendente que trabalha com marketing
só faltou dizer uma coisa daquela na
apresentação que foi mesmo livro ganhou
quem terminar a apresentação de outra
metade do sangue distrito a que eu
juntava os meus amigos lá em casa quando
ele me viu e e eu ainda sou do tempo do
revés o tempo de acerto e do vinil
juntava os meus amigos lá em casa e
gravar os programas de trabalho e de
muito tempo a fazer aqui o que obrigava
hoje faz mais ou menos a mesma coisa e
fixação soluções mais que se desfazendo
de suas gravações em cima das coisas e
falando esta minha actividade da rede
também também suas opções opções de
marcas estão todos marcas comportamento
do consumidor de que o que está aqui
hoje tem um cadáver com isto
provavelmente olhando para vocês ninguém
e sim o que está aqui criar as pessoas
não gostam de marcas é um bocado blog as
pessoas normais mas para quem trabalha
com os marcos porque trabalha no
marketing
esta coisa tenha cuidado de construir
rapidamente explica em linguagem do
martim godim dia e das marcas duchen
muito nessa coisa de nesta ideia de que
as pessoas querem ter relações que ele
tem compromisso com as marcas nossos
sonhos muito impactadas com isto é
pessoas que querem e esta explosão que
se usa agora no marketing como criar
querem se envolver com as marcas querem
a participarem
umidade do mar que estamos linguagem que
domina muito pensamento mágico em 2012
ea montagem das marcas na comunicação
das marcas mas é questão que e e é uma
coisa que de fato nós vemos isso
acontecer todos os dias essa imagem está
aqui foi a abertura da loja da po aí
porque as pessoas fizeram aquela fila
talkinho mas não estava em não está em
100% a afinada mas dá pra ver que as
pessoas tiram isto esta imagem muito
comum a facto marca que as pessoas
gostam muito se ligam a elas
mas essas mesmas marcas também são alves
foi roubado e ninguém quer uma um site
de redes sociais diz que se o preço do
iphone site consegue comprar um carro é
em quatro horas e contou algumas marcas
que conseguem de facto de ter essa coisa
de criar ações e criar homens
às 11 horas será que assim será que nós
temos mesmo nós do marketing e das
marcas
temos razão quando dizem que as pessoas
amam marcas querem marcas dos segmentos
exercício quantas marcas é que tem
vossas casas tem noção de quantas marcas
que tenham em casa cozinha despensa casa
de banho sala no carro
não sabemos nem com quantas marcas
daquelas que nós temos lá em casa que
nós possamos tomar que eu pensar eu peço
desculpas se alguém trabalha a pensar em
trabalho doméstico
somente três saber que um dos canos e
passa o menor do mês 13 323 não acontece
não acontece como a parte das marcas que
chico não é agora que vai vai parecer um
querido professor eu peço desculpa não
vai ver você é rápido é só para dizer
onde é que parece esta ideia que nós do
martins marques temos que as pessoas
querem envolver com as marcas que querem
falar com as marcas que querem criar um
deles aparece
lamento dizer o sim o problema bandeira
bandeira dos estados unidos só pra dizer
o marketing apareceu nos estados unidos
que a gente mesmo com quem está em
contato com martin cryans certamente o
conceito dos 4 p
martin links de outros conceitos do
marketing que aparecem estados unidos
anos 40 50 e 60 do século passado
grandes empresas pretendendo unilever
coca cola lançou esta coisa só que este
um site do marca então problema é um
conceito baseado na érico demasiado
virava para grandes empresas de produtos
de grande consumo que não é realidade na
maior parte das empresas do mundo
se calhar não é realidade das empresas
de serviço e aí que parece anos 80 os
tipos em frança começaram a pensar sim
se aplica para aquelas empresas
nossa proposta vício depois aparecer uns
tempos mas está em alguns países
nórdicos os tiros começaram a sair
neste dia 4 e desde marketing da pátria
lembro me leva a coca cola mas não se
aplica à realidade da maior parte das
empresas dos pequenos negócios das
pequenas indústrias e nós tivemos aqui
ouvi falar sobre uma posição das
associações sem fins lucrativos que
escancaram fazer uma coisa que foi
estudar os fenômenos martin com deus
acontecem nas redes do dia nas nossas
redes sociais
todos nós vivemos dentro das redes
sociais fizeram estes nove que fizeram
foi estudar o final de março nas redes
sociais que geram emoção nós portugueses
há muito tempo que temos um país
chegamos de o fato assim 01 outro nome é
marly martin das relações ou martin
erros nem nada a ver quem sabe sr e
mesas não tem nada a ver com isso
martin das relações próximas e muito
mais do que nós chamamos do final do
fator se da cunha e mesmo as emoções e
ele que parece este direito que a
existir outra coisa
nesta neste universo que nas empresas
de pequenos negócios da indústria
o marketing não é o marketing e
americano dos quatro pisos é o marketing
das relações é que o que mexe com as
emoções e nestas funções fato é como
quando nós vamos à tarde quando nós
vamos abrir e falamos cozinha do talho
onde seria criamos uma relação e há
qualquer coisa que creche ali naquela
relação e esse é o marco de 10 das
moções e e que por essa idéia
depois volta para a américa e já neste
sector os dias peço desculpas da parte
do ps que foi esta ideia volta para a
meta que é a mulherada então começa a
generalizar se
e hoje temos esta coisa que nós
conseguirmos teremos que criar prémios
ter relações com as marcas queremos
deixar as marcas é a desenvolver os seus
produtos e depressa coisa fantástica que
ter uma lógica de serviço dominante isto
é o marketing que hoje em dia já não é
melhor por aquela coisa do mato em
grande do sul
mas é preciso idéia de morte de martin
de serviço
ao mesmo tempo isso acontece mais um
momento da história
ao mesmo tempo isso acontece e acontece
outra coisa em cima de todos nós todos
nós não é guerra war é internet
desenvolve-se internet desenvolto uma
outra coisa mais que simplesmente em
cima da internet
no início do livro fala ao mesmo tempo
aparecem os sites de redes sociais quem
tem conta no facebook claro normal e
instagram - pressionar 18 uma coisa com
outra é só acionar as duas coisas
do nada para esses tipos de falar no
marketing de soluções e resoluções
utilizem para a história tudo ok e
serviços que depois aparecem internet
como o facebook sabe quantos
utilizadores é que existe um monitor no
facebook mas não viam 120 estandes das
marcas desindustrialização está aqui uma
coisa espetacular juntaremos por um
estudo que o facebook está nas redes
sociais as pessoas querem relacionar com
as marcas agora pergunto querem mesmo os
mesmos oceanos com as marcas dados com
um estudo feito com mais de 200 marcas
com de suas páginas do facebook vamos
ver se estas marcas
se conseguirmos fazer o mesmo com essas
vagas é que o 0,5 por cento estão ali
quer dizer só 0 5% do total do país
tendo uma daquelas marcas e que se
relaciona com a marca o que quer dizer
que está contrário 99 com 5% das pessoas
não quer então as pessoas não gostam de
marketing é uma coisa interessante dia
peço que todos estamos a falar de um
lado caem olha as marcas estuda as
marcas que querem demarcar estou a falar
neste lago e das pessoas que vivem as
marcas alto de sempre como lembra nós
trabalhamos na rádio em que a rádio pra
mim é muito importante porque depois da
minha família e dos meus amigos rádio é
brincar à rádio bandeirantes que
trabalha na rádio há muito sangue
desde tempos animais falavam sempre para
nós só trabalhamos aqui é muito
importante uma vez que o sol se dizer
assim é o lugar da carne na cozinha
quando se pergunta às pessoas qual é o
objeto é que ela está em na sua cozinha
de participar em 15º a 16º lugar
depois do canadá
ficamos triste em ver o santos e foi
importante com as pessoas pois nós mães
quando trabalhamos a marca interessante
que é de facto muito importante as
pessoas 90 e 99 1 pontos 5 por cento das
pessoas não é querem falar com as marcas
existentes nesse quadro que está aqui é
o crime tem muitos dados mais facilmente
laboa encontramos aquilo que suas marcas
pensão lapka aquilo que os consumidores
pensam e lá porque todas as pessoas
porque que os erros porque elas dão
lápis as marcas nas redes sociais
nomeadamente no facebook e no ainda
verde situado do lado das empresas do
lado os touros aparecem coisas como
aprender sobre os produtos informação
sobre os produtos vejam lia que é o site
sentir se humilhado por diferentes entes
ligada e vai fazer parte da unidade 61%
o que perguntamos às pessoas das duas
marcas
mas aos consumidores o que elas querem
ver o que elas querem
vejamos o que aconteceu a última coisa
que embaixo esquisito né porque o
pessoal das marcas não anda facto ouvir
os consumidores a falar então estes
dados devem fazer sempre lembrar uma
coisa é é quem já vou passar para a
parte final uma coisa senão vários com
menos uma é e isso é muito importante as
pessoas vivem enredo a vida em uma rede
social que se aplica para o facebook o
facebook é uma rede virtual é uma renda
real existem net redes virtuais o set
mais uma revista ou as pessoas não
parecem com pessoas aparecem com comum
avatar criam personagens no facebook não
todos nós conquistamos fim das férias as
pessoas saibam da nossa vida
o facebook é uma rede no rio real uma
rede resoluções reais então se nós da
nossa vida no nosso dia a dia não
passamos o tempo todo a falar marcas aos
outros o que queremos fazer no facebook
e uma outra coisa existente
a questão é as pessoas não gostam de
marcas
há sempre de braços entre algumas marcas
que as pessoas não querem e desejam o
procuram o que querem dizer qualquer
coisa sobre elas a pessoas que atuam
aqui tá lá e vencer
há pessoas que corta o cabelo em fahel
não posso as pessoas fazem simples do
que viu da data por exemplo deverá
sempre essas marcas nos dê tranqüilidade
dos casos as marcas ocupam um lugar réu
para na vida das pessoas porque sou está
em suas vidas
tem coisas muito mais importantes que
conquistou para como já vimos aqui hoje
a edição para as marcas para engenheiro
marca pertence porque se preocupe para
quem fala sobre marcas e são estas as
marcas devem continuar a esforçar-se
para atenção das pessoas
as marcas devem esforçar para
compreender as pessoas e é sobretudo uma
lição de humildade tem o seu papel no
que as pessoas têm suas vidas
talvez um dia se as marcas de 40 dessa
forma talvez um dia consiga conquistar o
coração de alguns consumidores e pelo
papel mais importante e é isto